[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre monsieur et madame les
ministres mes chers collègues
au-delà de la guerre et du devoir de
solidarité collective durable et sans
faille jusqu'à la libération de ce
peuple et le rétablissement de sa
souveraineté dans son territoire
internationalement reconnu au-delà de
cela je voudrais poser qui constitue
pour nous un impératif catégorique je
voudrais poser ici la question du sens
profond que revêt est à né aux yeux la
promesse d'adhésion de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne
porte-parole d'un groupe passionnément
attaché à la construction de l'Europe je
vous invite madame la Première ministre
à tordre le coup à l'idée perverse selon
laquelle c'est adhésion sonnerait le
glas de l'aventure communautaire telle
qu'elle appelle des Français des
Allemands nous l'avons conçu et mené à
partir du 9 mai 1950 nous faisons modem
le Paris inverse car nous attendons ce
grand rendez-vous un double
enrichissement de notre projet commun
l'Ukraine nous apprend par son courage
et par son héroïsme que le droit n'est
rien quand la force n'est pas que
l'exemplarité veine quand l'esprit de
résistance est absent et que l'Union
ne sera qu'une apparence si elle ne
donne celle de se donne pas les moyens
d'armer ses valeurs grâce à vous chers
amis du crâne nous faisons enfin notre
les paroles que tu sais dit prêtes à
Périclès il n'y a pas de bonheur sans
liberté ni de liberté sans vaillance
l'Ukraine nous rappelle au devoir de
vaillance mais nous lui proposons de
rejoindre le monde qui lui a toujours
été refusé un monde où la force nescue
pas le droit où l'on sait qu'on ne
défend vraiment ses intérêts légitimes
qu'à la condition de prendre en compte
les intérêts légitimes des autres un
monde où les gens sans visage au lieu de
se dévisager un monde qui n'ignore pas
qu'il n'est pas d'élargissement qui
vaille sans un solide renforcement des
institutions communes c'est la rencontre
de ces deux exigences qui fera de
l'Europe un acteur à part entière en
1051 de Kiev fille de jaroslave le sage
épousé Henri 1er le troisième capétien
est devenu ainsi reine de France Milan
au passé depuis lors et la princesse
dukraine naguère lointaine est désormais
toute proche
nous
et de retour parmi nous puissions-nous
madame la Première ministre mes chers
collègues l'accueillir pour ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui vraiment devenu une
immense figure de résistance qui s'est
donnée pour mission d'arracher nos
peuples désorientés alors somnolence
historique et qui pour parler comme
Malraux portent aux yeux du monde
l'honneur de toute l'Europe comme un
invincible
[Applaudissements]